[Music]
here's what i will tell you
i believe in being adequate or solid in
most things
and then figuring out what your three to
four superpowers are and become insane
in them
you've got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
you're in you're live great to hear you
well great great to be here i was saying
thank you so much for the kind intro and
i'm so excited to uh
to jam and hope everybody who's watching
on the other side is healthy and happy
and
thanks for having me absolutely so gary
we've had questions coming through today
and listen you've inspired me i know
you've inspired and touched the lives of
so many entrepreneurs
so grateful to have you i have a
question i'd love to kick off to you
before i start getting into the group
yeah so let me hit you with this so
we've been dealing obviously with the
global pandemic
obviously there's been stress and
anxiety
and business transition so many
different things some have been positive
and some have been negative but our
team's been working closely with our
clients to talk about cash resources and
how to maximize the cash that they have
available to them
i actually heard you speak about this at
the jobber event
a couple weeks ago which was super cool
i would love to hear your thoughts on
why individuals and businesses should
maximize their cash resources right now
well i think you know i'd love to get
the context of how you're thinking about
cash resources right because i think
there's so many different ways to play
like for example i'm going to say
something right now that i almost want
nobody to follow and i mean this i
for example besides putting a little
nest egg away
in cash for like the most rainy of rainy
of rainy days
i like the game of entrepreneurship and
business so much
and feel confident in it that most of
the things i do
are either a heavily investing in my own
businesses
more employees more resources more
offices
or extremely high risk investing
nfts you know um sports cards
you know so one of the reasons that i
actually don't talk a lot about
financial advice even though knock on
what i've done well is i think my
particular game
is very unique to me right you know how
people are really good at expect let's
use your background
you know i have a feeling hiking big
mountains is a good workout
but the reason that a lot of people
don't come out and say that's the thing
you should do is
most people will die climbing that
mountain
so i'd love to get clarification because
i want to give good advice to the masses
the way i do things is
safety net you know a little little
actual cash sitting
in a bucket and then offense because i
i'll tell you why and this makes me very
unique i've come to learn in my older
age
i'm not scared to go backwards i'm not
scared to be forced to sell my home and
rent
i'm not scared to fly commercial instead
of
first class i'm not scared to go through
an 18-month period where people
ridicule me for you know your friends
saying to you oh you love that gary vee
guy what about the fact that he just
lost all like
i'm such in a cocoon
that there's a level of lack of fear
that allows for higher risk
now i want to make sure everybody hears
this i am the furthest thing
from uh loose
ridiculous high crazy risk
i look risky when i put all my money
into facebook and twitter
all my financial advisors lost their
mind i knew
right yeah as i navigate through the nft
space 98 of nft projects are gonna go to
zero
but i put almost all my money into punks
and yesterday christie's announced that
they're doing a punk suction and
like i know what i'm doing so
before you know forget about you forget
about me everybody on the other side
here you first know yourself this is a
game of self-awareness
and then you filter good advice i i
caught the tail end of your last thing
i said i gotta give this guy some credit
that raise your price
uh advice is such a good one because it
always works out because the downside is
people say no and nothing bad happened
and the upside is 86 of the people that
are going to do it
that just hurt you all of them are going
to get some some level of
increase it's one of these amazing games
of perception
so i know i've gone long-winded because
i love to give some context but
clear it up for me if so i can
definitely answer a question but the way
i think about things is actually
opposite sides very very safe i'm
stunned by how many people go fully into
debt have no cash reserves
if everything goes to [ __ ] don't have
some money to at least rent an apartment
and
live life and on the flip side i go with
my strengths i understand
nfts better than i understand real
estate think about that for a minute i
understand how to invest in nfts right
this minute
better than i know how to invest in real
estate
i that probably puts me in a group of
like 13 people on earth because even the
other people that know how to do nfts
probably no real estate enough like
so you've got to know yourself but go
ahead my friend totally so
when we're talking about this we're
talking about business owners and we're
talking about that safety net like you
just said
because from my perspective and i'd love
your take on this
that over the next 12 months there's
gonna be so much
change there's going to be retirement
people closing their doors if you have
the safety net and you have the cash
resources
you can go all in on you as an
entrepreneur
and really take over some market share
right so that's what i was thinking
about
let me let me tell you why you're right
about that but let me tell you why my
answer is a lit was a little different
and i think we're going to combine the
two
you're right i do think that incredible
fortunes are about to be built because a
lot of weird stuff's about to happen
i also know that here we are given some
advice
and people look at us and then go and do
something that feels
uncomfortable because like well this is
my time
i've been playing it safe and look at
these two right
and then i know a geopolitical climate
thing happens
china invades india america decides to
declare war
uh there's a terrorist attack at the
highest levels in america first one
in 20 years um there's a
cyber attack on amazon cloud and every
like
there's these such big events that are
out of your and i's purview
that if the timing is wrong and people
overextend themselves in a way that they
can't go to zero
which is financial and emotional
then they're dead and then we gave bad
advice so notice what i did
if you listen to my answer have a have a
little cash
in case everything goes to zero so you
can rent and and buy clothes and eat
food
so a bigger one right the bigger one is
can you deal with the ridicule if you
lose my biggest problem with the
what i know in my soul is that 97 of the
people on this
call right now this video this
conference
wouldn't do well if their sister made
fun of them saying you thought you were
a big shot see you're just like me or
their mom or their girlfriend or their
boyfriend or
and that's the game that's where my
content has evolved
because i didn't understand why this was
all easy for me
it was that part it's not that i'm
smarter or better
it's that i have an incredible
relationship
with outside validation aka i have no
need
totally yeah no and i can completely
appreciate that and
for my advice with any of our
entrepreneurs that we work with it's
always to keep that safety net and
always to make sure that we have that
so don't don't overextend yourself by
any stretch but knowing that
so many things are going to change if
you can find the right areas to invest
right now
you're probably going to have a really
big impact and make a lot of change
there's going to be an incredible and i
mean incredible amount of opportunity
because in a year the whole world's
going to be different because we're
going to be
coming back and all the rules changed
no more stimulus checks
people have learned how to do business
on zoom
college doesn't look like the same value
prop
relationships have changed nuances have
changed buying behaviors have changed
how people find out about things have
changed
things have changed yeah things have
definitely
and will continue to change right yes
but this was big brother
right the things that i've been living
through for the last 20 years have been
gradual
gradual gradual
do you know many people that are 55 to
65 that were
super tech illiterate and didn't want to
were forced to learn
and now love it that's a consumer
behavior shift
but totally and they had no other choice
if they wanted to communicate with
people
or have interaction right i know that
that worked for us it extended our
boundaries
we could serve everywhere correct
correct think about you know the way i
travel
now i'm not gonna go to the same you
know um
you know meetings which means i'm not
gonna be in colorado which is gonna have
a negative impact on the hotel business
like
like you know now i'll still travel a
bunch but it's gonna be a mix
and that's a big change so change uh
so i want to move on to more questions
because i want to get as many answers as
we can out of you gary while we have the
time
uh you've said that not every day is
easy in being
in business i'm sure we can all relate
to that especially in 2020
but i would love to hear what it is that
you do to cope
and get through those tough days when
you do have them
gratitude perspective
you know not caring about money over the
health of the people you love
old school [ __ ] grandparents [ __ ] you
know
i'm just too grateful for what i have
to be sad about what i don't have
or what i just lost in the short term in
business
my relationship with business is
extraordinary i i
i don't think most people are going to
believe what i'm about to say but
when i die i hope that they can take
your dna and tell the truth of someone
i i dream about modern technologies
um i i
desperately
don't care about the money
yeah it's very easy to deal with bad
stuff
when you when you because this is what i
play my friend i play the
what if this thing didn't go bad
actually my business doubled
but on the way to go sign the paperwork
that doubled my business or the client
called me and said we've given you all
the business
that the next phone call was my mother
had a heart attack and i'm going extreme
but i'm just telling
you the truth of how i deal with it you
ask the question i'm giving you the real
answer absolutely
it's perspective like i can't
care enough about it if
the people i love are healthy today i
mean it my kryptonite
is the health and well-being of my
family totally and i think we're all in
there and i
know and i don't but i but i think
people don't mean it
i'm being honest with you yeah like i
think everyone says it
but i watch my whole life i'm you know
i'm 45 now i've been in the game a long
time like
because i did it right from the
beginning as a kid people don't act like
that
yeah they say it but do they really mean
it because if they meant it they
wouldn't overreact
and get so emotional and hit the bottle
drinking or
too many people's affirmation is around
how much money they make
totally not you know ideally there's
more
right there's definitely more to life
than this now listen and i love it
listen don't get it wrong i'm not foofy
foofy gene like out of a genie out of a
bottle here i'm not poofy
i'm an entrepreneur i'm trying to kill
every i'm trying to win the game i'm
trying to do it i love it
i love the game but it's a game
totally and so like i'm that kind of
person that plays basketball to kill
but i know it's just a game and when
it's over how's your family this and
that
and that's how i treat business so
speaking of games
so i woke up last night or i guess this
morning at 3 30 excited
but it was to figure out what question i
wanted to ask you today
i've got a bunch and i know there's a
bunch from the crowd my question was we
just went through identifying goals how
to make them
smart specific measurable attainable
realistic timely
and i woke up thinking gary vee has got
a goal that is to buy the new york jets
i've got to know is that following that
sort of principle
is it attainable is it timely when is
that time gonna happen for you gary i
can't wait to pop the champagne for you
one of the great misnomers about me
is that my goal is to try to buy the new
york jets
more than it is to buy the jets and let
me explain what i mean by that so
what's going on with that i think i'm
going to do it brother i think i'm going
to pull it off of course you are
of course you know um now listen even if
i mask that extreme wealth which is a
very difficult task
there's the serendipity of them selling
it at the time that i'm liquid enough to
do this
so the math is actually incredibly
against me but i believe it
but my happiness comes from the striving
to do it
the process the strategic chess moves to
get there
much much more than actually i would
actually argue that the day i buy the
new york jets
is the day that i'm most unhappy
because the thrill of the hunt it's kind
of like vacations i i love vacationing i
love
sleeping and vacationing i think people
think of me as this one you know i need
balance like everybody else i just love
my thing so much that it
makes it seem like i'm always you know
but man do i love a good vacation
and when the week up to the vacation
brother i'm losing my mind i'm so
into it i'm so excited anticipation the
second
plane lands i start to get a little
depressed because i know i'm on the
other side of the anticipation but
that's the on that's the
the entrepreneurial vision of attaining
a goal as soon as you pass it you go
well now what the hell am i going to do
right it's deflating
so ultimately you know buying the jets
is going to be something you're going to
track
for a long time and then once you do it
maybe it'll be buying
another maybe a basketball franchise
gary
i think for me then it's going to be
because i'm going to be an older man
because i'm playing it long so i'll
probably
not older actually my one of my 45 you
know i'd love to think i can get it by
65
i hope the next 20 years are compounding
um
then i'm going to focus on winning a
super bowl brother because that's why i
want to buy that i'm sick and tired of
not having one
yeah winners create winners absolutely
so listen i've got another question here
uh i've heard you say that if you fight
against
technology you will lose what technology
should we be investing in right now
you should definitely get in in
understanding around nfts because it
will affect all your businesses now that
doesn't mean go buy the collectibles and
the art on nfts
but the what's called the ledger the
blockchain
smart contracts this is something people
need to know everybody here should spend
20 hours of reading or watching youtube
videos
or listening to clubhouse get educated
don't
get caught up in the gold rush it's
going to be just like 99 2000
internet internet internet and what did
most people do they bought internet
stocks
they bought them at 60 they went to 200
they thought they were geniuses and then
literally literally in two weeks they
all went to a dollar
why because everything was too frothy on
the hype it wasn't practical
and both were right it was too frothy
and that's why it shouldn't want to a
dollar but the internet was the biggest
technology change of our society
in a long time same with nfts
non-fungible tokens built on the
blockchain
often on blockchains like ethereum but
others flow others
are the biggest shift in our universe in
a long long time
and they people will do their mortgages
on it they'll do
their book releases on it your your next
book is going to be an nft that comes
with the book
it's coming i'm telling you it's coming
i know most of the people don't even
know what i'm talking about right now
that's the one to not bet against i'm
i'm very bullish on it i believe in it
but as you can see i gave you the
caveats of where
there's going to be some beanie babies
like activities in the short term but in
the long term there's going to be some
real business opportunities
absolutely so let's talk about social
media
like i never see anybody post as much as
you it's incredible you're
inspiring to so many people what's the
advice to the business owner who maybe
isn't
doing any regular posts on social media
what is it that they're missing out on
opportunity it's not like a necessity
you're missing out on opportunity not
necessity you're just leaving
business growth on the table
so what would be you know let's say two
things that each business owner should
do with social media tomorrow
to optimize this opportunity
one is very macro one's very micro i'll
start with micro
everybody here watching this right now
should be posting two original pieces of
content
on linkedin every day linkedin is a gold
mine right now with organic reach
you don't even have to pay for the ads
it reaches people
and everybody in this business community
can really benefit from it and it's kind
of like facebook was in 2012.
it's a gold mine of organic reach
organic reach for everybody's
understanding means when you just post
and just people see it you don't have to
pay for it some of you here who did well
with facebook pages know exactly what
i'm talking about
seven years ago you post hundreds of
thousands today thousands
it's not as good you have to spend money
now to get more that's not bad that
facebook did that that's called supply
and demand
there's more ads there's less people
consuming supply and demand
linkedin is still here don't do it don't
start
when it's here do it right now that's
the that's the micro
the macro is self-awareness most people
don't social media
produce because they haven't figured out
what they're best at audio
video or written word people think
everything has to be video
it doesn't if you're a great writer
write your little heart out
if you want to take a picture to get a
little color and then write
then do that if you have the gift of gab
you should definitely do audio and video
because it does go
further but it doesn't mean written word
or pictures don't
people have not been self playing this
self-awareness game of what am i good at
enough and that's the other big part how
do you communicate well
what's your take on clubhouse
i think it's going to end up having the
history of snapchat which is it's going
to be a great standalone thing but every
other social platform will have a
audio group feature and we've already
seen it with twitter spaces i think
you're gonna see it everywhere so
i think it's got legs because the
founders are good they raise a lot of
money
and they'll keep making a product but i
think they'll be chipped away at
and i think it's going to be just like
snapchat that there'll be a nice solid
thing there but a lot of people
have um their versions on it on their
platforms
so and so vayner media manages some of
the biggest brands in the world right
now what is your thought with where
marketing
is going is it going towards voice
i i think it's always been a voice radio
has always gotten a lot of
ad dollars podcasting gets a lot of bad
dollars
i think yes obviously and i appreciate
the question because obviously you're
close to my content and you know i'm
very bullish on voice
i think the big elephant in the room is
augmented reality
you know augmented excuse me artificial
intelligence ai
voice alexa i think alexa's
lulling us to sleep everyone has one but
they're using it for music we're not
really using it yet but i'm completely
convinced before everybody here dies
that they'll be ordering food running
their house
looking at their account list excuse me
listening to their calendar alexa what's
my next meeting
that kind of stuff i think that's coming
in the next decade and so
i do like voice a lot but i think
brand building on social is still an
unknown art doing brand work there every
day that's where brand is being built
because that's where the eyeballs are i
think ott hulu
roku amazon prime ads
it's taking away from television is a
very big space i think influencers
continues to be a big space i think nft
projects will
emerge as a big space in the next decade
totally um okay question
from social media for you um
sometimes the entrepreneurial journey
can be exhausting and draining
how have you dealt with times of burnout
and what would be your advice
on those who are in that place right now
to take time my ability to not judge
myself
when i'm mailing it in for a month a
week a year
a weekend is my greatest superpower as
an entrepreneur
i don't judge myself
see and it's it's funny too right the
perception of you or i think maybe some
of the
comments about you is that you work 365
seven days a week right but i
i'd actually just recently seen your
schedule of your days that you take off
right and maybe that's a really great
insight for those people who think you
have to work
24 7 365. i work 24 367 360 247
365 in my brain
out of enjoyment the second it's not
enjoyment
i watch the jets the second it's not
enjoyment
i play with the ball the second it's not
enjoyment
i play pickup basketball i work out i go
see my parents
i play with the kid like i the reason i
work so much is because i like it the
way that people like golf
and skiing and cooking and running
and watching tv and playing video games
and eating
i like it more it's my hobby
but i like anybody else i'll give you a
great story
texas banned us from shipping wine they
just picked on us
our store happens politics
so we lose this huge market nobody else
is losing it feels unfair i'm 28.
i get the final death blow at 1 30 p.m i
literally drive home and go to sleep at
2 p.m
slept the next morning and was on my way
only time it's ever happened in my
career it was just such a death blow
because i was scared
we lost a lot of revenue and we're a
small company and
and we were being picked on it all
sucked it's you know i love losing
but not when it's a stacked deck and
it's not a fair game totally
so you know i um
to answer everybody like don't be a hero
don't front
i'm working every second because i love
it but i don't work on the weekends
i think about my business sometimes
sometimes i don't it's just
whatever i feel i just live i feel what
i just live
who are you doing it for to act cool to
your uncle to
to impress your girlfriend or boyfriend
like what are we doing here
love yourself love that gary
i got a question here from steven raynor
says
i'm a grade 12 student who really wants
to make money in any way possible
sure way to go steven that's awesome uh
i currently have a part-time job but i
don't feel that i'm making nearly as
much as i should
recently i've taken up investing and
have mild success with that
however i really want to start a side
hustle but i can never fully commit to
my
ideas that i have how do i fix this and
just go for it
you're fatally flawed that's why my
friend your
your kpi your key performance indicator
your goal is money of course you're not
sticking to anything
you're impatient and you want money so
fast
nothing in the history of time takes off
right away so you give up on everything
because the only thing you're thinking
about is fast money there's no such
thing
and so unless you do criminal activity
or shady [ __ ]
and so because of that you're in this
hamster wheel of no
chance of winning you've got to realize
your goal of making money
is your flaw you know and um
live your passion right you you know
the the the key is
to you know live your passion something
i believe in but i think it gets frothy
for people
i'd rather say if you're doing it for
money it will
always always be a struggle emotionally
always
absolutely uh i've got a question from
dylan and it's around
you know he's building a business on his
own has an opportunity to expand and
bring
on partners expertise maybe even venture
capital
what's your thought on that should
somebody consider
still doing it on their own and
bootstrapping it or
should they be looking at partnering up
venture capital
giving away a piece both work
and both don't work that's a
self-awareness game do you want to be
held accountable i've never really
raised capital because i don't want to
answer to anybody so i'd rather go
slower
some people feel like competition is
going to be coming in soon so the
capital
give them a bigger moat they both work
um i have historically not been a guy
that loves raising money
i'm not against it i have raised money
um so
i you know i think there's a million
ways to do it but um
but i think it's a very person that's
kind of like asking somebody to raise
their children
like you know like you've got to raise
your children your way
they both work don't take money because
it's cool
take money because you actually believe
you need it
totally uh from tim jablonski
gary has talked about focus on what
you're good at and double down on that
but as entrepreneurs we're told to
sharpen or broaden our skills
or even get better at what we need to
work on what's a reasonable balance
80 20 60 40.
sure you know i'll tell you why this
dance was sure
hey i'm i always think about the
audience when i talk
so somebody's 80 20 is 60 40. so i'm
scared to give an answer
here's what i will tell you i believe in
being adequate
or solid in most things and then
figuring out what your three to four
superpowers are
and become insane in them that is i
fully believe in that i think people get
caught up on the other stuff
this is why i build family like
atmospheres because i want to have
people around me for a long
time that are good at legal that are
good at finance that are good at
project management that are good at
spelling because i can't spell for [ __ ]
but for me i'm not going to go take a
spelling class
or you know i'm not going to let my cfo
rip me off but at the same token i'm not
going to spend every second looking at
every dollar
you know and so we're we're trying to
learn every nuance about ebitda
you know and so i think that um you know
i'm a big fan of tripling down in your
strengths but you have to be adequate
nothing can be a fatal
flaw right it's like a body you could be
everything but if you don't work out
your legs and then your
inner thighs you know it's gonna all
[ __ ] you up and so i'm
i'm i'm i'm into adequacy solidness
in a lot of areas and i'm i think people
don't triple
because you understand you only have so
much energy so when you're fixing all
that other stuff you're not taking like
let's use numbers
if you're an eight eight eight and then
you're a six two four nine seven
you gotta get that two to five but but
getting that five to a six
is more effort than your eight to a nine
and the delta of that eight to the nine
in
sales in management in hr in finance
whatever that is
that's gonna make a much bigger impact
than all the energy you put on those
fives to become sixes
because you're never going to be innate
because we're all dna'd out
so you brought up your cfo and and i
wasn't going to talk finances
even though i'm a finance guy how
important is it for you to have somebody
reliable that you can trust
running the helm of your finances for
you so you can do your thing and you can
double down on that
it's oxygen can't pay your bills you're
out of business game over
totally you know i i also need a partner
who understands me
alan and i are into about five years now
we're starting to get into a really good
cadence where i'm on the offense
i give big shout out to mark yudkin my
co he plays a great bridge because he's
started off as my general counsel and he
really knows me been together 15 years
and
you know i don't want a cfo to play
defense
i can i can bean count totally i need
somebody who knows
what like supports my offense so
imperative
totally i had a text message come
through from one of my
virtual cfo clients we do virtual cfo
work and he said to me today
you know good luck kick ass on your
event and he goes just remember
that you were the one person that when i
said i'm going to get a billion dollars
in revenue in my business in the next 10
years
you didn't laugh at me you said we'll
figure out a way and i think that that's
a key
partnership with the cfo that you are
being proactive
and you're helping accomplish the goals
instead of putting up rules and barriers
is that fair 100 unbelievably right
cfos a lot of times think they run the
business
and that is their flaw because they have
signing authority
correct yeah and and i have a lot of
empathy for that
but it's just not the truth and
companies that are run by cfos
always limit their upside totally
yeah we're playing safe which is fine
nobody wants to go out of business i'm
not
i'm not advocating for careless fake
entrepreneurship
i'm advocating for vision driven offense
entrepreneurship
totally you want the green light you
look to the green light to say can i do
this and should i do this or will it
[ __ ] me
because i want i'm looking i'm not even
looking for the green light i'm looking
for the conversation
yeah that lets me decide if i want to go
green yellow or red
totally and and what the cfo should be
looking for is the kind of partner like
i am which is
oh after i heard it i'm like [ __ ] that
idea
totally yeah absolutely guys you heard
it first gary vee
he's endorsing having a great cfo
partner though
that is awesome i also am endorsing and
i know that this is this domain and i
absolutely am i'm also endorsing
even more this is not a curveball or raz
having a great hr partner human
human aspects of business are about to
explode even more
and i think that people are more often
good at having a good cfo partner than
having a good hr partner
totally agree with that yeah or back to
your point
i think there's foofy and i'm a little
foofy at times buddha
people that are really good at hr and
they're good ceo but don't have the cfo
partner
you got to get that whole thing going
right you need your team of advisors
right
you need a solid team of advisors
because they help you stay on track and
inspire you to
do your thing i think i'm really good i
really do
and i have a lot of capacity but it is
very clear to me with these gray hairs
that have emerged
that i'm as good as the people that are
around me and when i have the team right
around me
then i can fly and when i don't it's
much more work and i don't get as much
done
totally gary another question i know
you're writing another book i know it's
going to be a new york times bestseller
because that's what you do
any insight as to what's in there i've
heard a few snippets
of you know talking about gratitude and
it's more maybe related to the human
side versus the marketing side
love to hear a little bit it's a
it's a book around the ingredients
needed
emotionally to really be a winner
in business and so it is
more towards a leadership mindset
kind of like thank you economy right
it's a point of view book
but it's real practical i my publisher
who's on book number six with me said
it's by far my best book in her notes
yesterday
i don't need outside of affirmation it
was nice to hear but there was the whole
time drock was filming me
as i was talking it through with ragab
i'm like holy [ __ ] this is gonna be my
best book
i think it's gonna be a smash hit i'm
very excited about it
i'm always anxious when i ask people for
money
so i always say why will this be worth
20 bucks why will this be worth 20 bucks
i've never felt better about the 20
bucks
than this book uh and
uh it's gonna be really fun well every
year you get scars in business
in learning you create new wealth of
information
and sharing so i can just imagine you
know the 10th book is going to be the
best book you ever write
whenever you get there um
question for you here uh it's talking
about open rates on newsletters
uh how do you recommend increasing this
do you recommend
getting away from newsletters what's the
best way i know
that you were really quick on email
marketing really quick on youtube and
video
what's the next marketing step that we
need to take
sms open rates on text are through the
roof
obviously the way you get better open
rates on email
is by not making every email a
selfish email make it a selfless email
think of your email services not just a
sales funnel think of it as a content
engine
so if you can add one email a week that
is just desperately
focused on bringing value to the person
who's reading it from a content
standpoint
you'll go to a totally different
stratosphere with your open rates
you got to throw it off steep off speed
pitch everyone's throwing a fastball
every time on email
totally yeah and people are getting sick
of it too right
to a certain extent yeah correct one
more question here
uh from maria gary how do you work
through feelings
of jealousy and envy i have an
experience with someone that is doing
something in excel better than me i got
jealous and it made me question my
mission
how do i snap back into an abundance
mentality
i love her was it her or him or did you
give a name maria
maria i love you so much for having the
ability to
acknowledge it um jealousy
and envy come from a place of fear
comes from a place of uh scarcity
great job by talking about abundance at
the end of your question
and it comes from a place of insecurity
and lack of self-esteem
you have you the fact that you even know
this in question form
makes me completely positive you can get
there um
you're gonna have to work on it you're
gonna have to put positivity in your
ears
whether it's therapy whether it's
surrounding yourself with positive
people
when i tell you the greatest gift in my
life is my lack of jealousy and envy
it goes back to that not needing
affirmation from the outside
it's the same thing of why you want
money it's just the reverse of that
i couldn't and i mean couldn't be more
passionate
about pushing you to keep going down
this path
because you're you're heading in the
right direction it's a
the answer to the question is because it
doesn't mean anything like someone
else's success legitimately has nothing
else to do with you
right so excuse me for one second i
gotta figure out what that is
hopefully it's not lunch ready gary
guys garyvee is incredible throw in your
comments in here for when he comes back
in the chat what is the most inspiring
meaningful message that you've heard
from garyvee throw it in the chat
let's give him some love when he comes
back from his
lunch being done in the oven i would
love for that
guys we have garyvee on here this is
incredible what an
opportunity to talk with one of the
masters of entrepreneurship
one of the masters of
essentially resonating with gratitude
and sharing
how important it is for the human side
of business
right garyvee is an inspiration to so
many of us
and you know i'm super grateful that
he's here
i'm hopefully gonna find out that he's
coming back
um because he may have just had somebody
at the door
but it's all good i apologize gary
there's love coming from you
in the chat my friend we are so
appreciative
of you and your time i know you're a
busy guy i would love to ask you one
last question before you need to run
and hopefully that wasn't lunch being
overcooked in the oven there gary
if it was if it was lunch i would have
never left an important conference like
this i'm waiting on one family thing and
i just had to triple check it wasn't
that
no worries my friend so one piece of
advice i would love to know
one piece of advice that you would share
to an entrepreneurial community
to say how do you get from where you are
now
to realizing you know your true future
the future that you're destined to
achieve the goals
and the vision that you want to
accomplish in your life
repeat that one more time because i want
to really nail that yeah so one piece of
advice
that we could give the entrepreneurial
community that would help them get from
where they are today
to really realizing their passion
realizing their vision
and what they want to get out of life
what is it the one piece of advice that
we can give them to head out of this
session
to really nail that put your two
index fingers in your ears and close
your eyes
and live your life that way i am
completely convinced about this at this
point in my life
the outside noises and trying to achieve
for them
back to the last question right is
is a death blow do you know why
you know when people meet me in real
life and really actually get to know me
inevitably because of where my life has
gone
within the first hour or day
or week of knowing someone somebody says
to me
just can't believe how humble you are
right and it's a couple reasons they say
that i've amassed some success i'm also
quite hyper and content i get it right
but the reason i'm hyper
is the same reason that i can deal with
negativity
i don't hear the cheering i don't think
i'm the garyvee that you introd
i really don't i'm being serious i
really don't
by not hearing the accolades and the
cheering
it also allows me not to hear the booing
almost everybody here is playing for the
crowd
i'm playing for myself what you just
asked
is the easiest question i've ever been
asked it's a very simple answer
and it's almost impossible to achieve
because people don't practice gratitude
and insuliness on a daily basis and i do
and it's really worked for me and i see
it in many others
and i see how it's worked for them
absolutely love that guys share some
love for gary v in the chat
before he goes gary v even though you
may not see yourself as that inspiration
that's certainly how i perceive you
don't i know you never will change but
don't change your social media man i
love
i love love love seeing your notes of
inspiration and motivation
even your chats your texts your sms that
come through
love getting those too my friend listen
i am so grateful for you
thanks for making time for us uh have an
awesome day and
guys a little uh spirit fingers for
garyvee to head them out
youtube watcher what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon
you